[ Seagulls squawking ]
-Go, go, go, go.
♪♪
1, 2, 3.
♪ In the town where I was born ♪
♪ Lived a man
who sailed to sea ♪
♪ And he told us
of his life ♪
♪ In the land of submarines ♪
♪ So we sailed up to the sun ♪
♪ Till we found
a sea of green ♪
♪ And we lived
beneath the waves ♪
♪ In our yellow submarine ♪
-1, 2, 3!
♪ We all live
in a yellow submarine ♪
♪ A yellow submarine,
a yellow submarine ♪
♪ We all live
in a yellow submarine ♪
♪ A yellow submarine,
a yellow submarine ♪
♪ And our friends
are all aboard ♪
♪ Many more of them
live next door ♪
♪ And the band began to play ♪
♪ Ba-ba-ba-da,
ba-da, ba-da ♪
ba-da, ba-da, da-da ♪
♪ We all live
in a yellow submarine ♪
♪ A yellow submarine,
a yellow submarine ♪
♪ We all live
in a yellow submarine ♪
♪ A yellow submarine,
a yellow submarine ♪
-Full speed ahead, Mr. Parker!
Full speed ahead.
Full speed ahead it is,
Sergeant.
Action station, action station!
-Where are we heading?!
-Over there!
That's right!
Let's go!
-Captain, captain!
-♪ As we live a life of ease ♪
♪ Every one of us ♪
-♪ Every one of us ♪
-♪ Has all we need ♪
-♪ Sky of blue ♪
-♪ Sea of green ♪
-♪ In our yellow ♪
-♪ Submarine ♪
-Ha ha!
-♪ We all live
in a yellow submarine ♪
♪ A yellow submarine,
a yellow submarine ♪
♪ We all live
in a yellow submarine ♪
♪ Yellow submarine,
a yellow submarine ♪
♪ We all live
in a yellow submarine ♪
♪ A yellow submarine,
a yellow submarine ♪
♪ We all live
in a yellow submarine ♪
♪ A yellow submarine,
a yellow submarine ♪
[ Bell dinging ]
[ Seagulls squawking ]